thanks I'm Dan I primarily gave a talk
on I primarily gave a talk on Python
libraries for hardware in silicon design
which many of the attendees told me was
like being on acid
but I'll spend five minutes on something
that hopefully is applicable to more of
us something we're all here doing at
some level which is teaching from
teaching and learning from each other
and going to this conference you see
most folks use a slide presentation like
this I see a few of you are brave enough
to do something like this guy in the
highwire doing live coding the folks who
use jupiter for this i think it's a
great tool for that but what i really
want to talk about is an element that
even the live coding
talks don't have which is some
interaction and believe it or not this
will be a five-minute interactive
presentation so i encourage you to have
your laptop or phone ready for about
minute three but i want to show a couple
problems I consistently see when we try
to do this first one if I'm trying to
teach you a library introduce an idea
step one is often start installing stuff
okay if you have nice tools like pip
this isn't so hard if you have other
languages maybe languages to start with
see it could be a lot harder at best
it's wasting time that we could actually
be learning from each other second if I
want to give you a complicated narrative
a complicated story
we might often start with something
simple step one do something sort of
uncomplicated step two use it and then
70 plus steps later when we get to step
73 which use steps 1 through 72 we've
got this very cool elaborate thing built
only problem being if you fell off the
track in steps 1 through 72 you're done
you're out worst of all even worse is no
one else knows that you fell off the
track maybe not even you certainly not
me or everyone else with along with you
and forth this should be fun this should
be part of a game to be able to go back
and forth and learn from each other
so I've been kicking the tires on making
a tool to get around these problems to
have this set of stuff and what I'm
gonna encourage you to do now I'm sorry
this isn't displaying very well but
class with a K dot live slash pike on de
will take you to a length it looks like
this which somebody's already beaten me
to which will have a scoreboard talking
about the game element and what I've
done is set up behind the scenes a
server where a container for a server or
where something like Jupiter is running
and we're presented with something like
the notebook interface where I've a
combination of markdown in code cells
but are organized into sort of problems
that I've got my solution to the meaning
of life sort of pre coded but very much
like in Jupiter form shift-enter
submits a response you can do this as
well that fails my past one passes we
can see everyone's on the scoreboard
great now what I'm gonna do as the host
is jump us ahead to the next problem
which is where we're gonna introduce a
little more fun thing which is let's
hear your favorite type now this is
where the game it's another level more
interesting because this is a question
where there's some room for debate
there's a room for different answers and
what we'll be able to do is a review but
everybody had to say and whether it
worked or not whether it's working or
not is based on the tests I provided
which do scoring on the server in the
environment that everyone is using
dedicated to this session so this is
call this is what I've been kicking the
tires on for a little while if you're
trying to teach people to use a library
or do things kind of like the tutorials
here and this seems like a it seems like
any form of a good idea
hit me up here around the conference or
you can email me here and thanks very
much for
pretty time
[Applause]